in a world consumed by greed apathy and
terribly paced storytelling
there is a place of escape
a space with hope kindness and tv shows
where every episode has a beginning
middle and end instead of all of them
being segments of a six hour movie
but this is a place lost a time
inaccessible now to those with attention
spans and free time outside of work
alas this forbidden world is a relic of
a bygone era we will never again be able
to live in harmony within
the gutter space special thanks to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
stick around for later to hear more
about squarespace disney plus as moon
knight finally has a trailer and i have
the feeling that almost all of this
footage is from the first episode which
is a good thing i think starting the
show with one of mark spector's
alternate personalities living in
everyday life and then discovering all
of the other lives he leads is a great
way to start a fresh take on moon night
steven grant is the vehicle for the
audience to be introduced to the wacky
and weird world of moon knight and
that's fitting because he's the only
alter that doesn't take part in any
violence he's just a mousy pacifist
businessman guy i never thought about
giving him an english accent before but
i think it works for further
distinguishing him from the other two
guys so that's a cool idea
why did you call me mark
although i'm painfully aware that this
is going to be a watered-down pg-13 show
because he jumps over a disney logo at
the end and that just feels so
it's like you've got this dark and
violent character jumping over something
i so heavily associate with children's
entertainment and silly cartoon animals
dancing it's like if the punisher fired
a bullet in slow motion and we zoomed in
on it and had a nickelodeon logo on it
moments before exploding a crime boss's
head into orange slime okay that would
actually be really funny we don't see a
lot of his costume but i really dig the
design it's not really going for that
typical mcu tactical military look and i
appreciate that i think it's a great
idea to make him so much of a mummy
because it fits the egyptian theme and
it's so mummy-ish that that comparison
is more obvious than saying he looks
like a klansman because his hood looks
awfully pointy sometimes so that he gets
that was a good design choice 11 out of
10. he doesn't look like a grand wizard
other than that i don't know what you
want from me i still don't have enough
information to say if it's good or not
all i'm seeing is a bunch of out of
context random clips of steven [ __ ]
his pants i don't know why all of you
guys in my mentions are going bro looks
like they really got it right it looks
so dark and cool and radical bro they
really did the character justice bro i
did my breakdown of all the things i did
and didn't want to see in this show a
few months before wandavision started so
i was speculating by the metrics of
marvel netflix because that was more
current but now i've seen all the disney
plus shows so i can say that it'll have
a strong first two episodes the third
episode will be boring and terrible the
fourth one will be the worst one by far
the fifth one will be a little bit
better kind of a glimmer of hope and
then the sixth episode will just end
weirdly abruptly because nobody knows
how to pace and edit movies anymore then
we'll see about 40 minutes of important
character development via deleted scenes
that were cut for time so they could
focus more on quote-unquote witty
dialogue with the hopes it'll become
heavily quotable memes for 14 year olds
then that show will be held on a
pedestal by that fan base as high cinema
because they're children and haven't
seen any other movies so doing the bare
minimum to tell a halfway decent mystery
story with some mildly trippy visuals
will seem like the coolest thing ever
in the same way that a greasy fast food
cheeseburger is cool to a 25 year old
who grew up in a cave only eating plain
bread and stale water once you [ __ ]
kids watch a movie directed by panos
cosmotost if you want something that's
actually a mind trip god i sound like
such a cynical old man now i've become
my father but yeah the trailer is a big
ol fine in my books
it's fine i'm still not convinced they
did moon knight properly but i'm
hoping to being proven wrong i was
really ready to hate loki because i
thought doing a series on that character
was pointless after his arc was
completed but they took it in such a
cool direction that i think it justified
itself it had a somewhat dark tone and
it tackled some interesting
philosophical concepts about time how
propaganda and misinformation props up
fascist ideals
life and death and free will under the
rule of an omniscient higher power with
an inscrutable plan
it had some really great visuals and
some of my favorite character moments in
the entire mcu but of course everyone
hates that show because it has a
character ship they don't really like
because these people watch these movies
like their big budget episodes of
friends
rossen rachel ew
so if it's closer to wanda vision title
too long or hawkeye i'll probably find
it pretty boring and forgettable but if
it's closer to loki i might just think
it's
kind of cool we'll see what happens this
is uh a variety news show so i'll talk
about other stuff too if you're one of
those 7 000 new subs from last month i
uh haven't done one of these in a while
so that's the format i'll talk about a
bunch of stuff it'll be funny i promise
don't click off hold on please i've got
other things to say in other oscar isaac
news apocalypse poe dameron is playing
miguel o'hara and across the
spider-verse because hollywood only uses
the same 20 actors for everything the
trailer looks pretty cool
apparently every universe they go to
will have its own unique art style and
i'm hoping to see some legitimate 2d
animation in there too i'm just really
hoping they don't go to the universe
from the 90s cartoon because that'll
completely invalidate my fan comic and
also probably really piss off the
creator of that show because he believes
he should be credited with the
spider-verse concept i don't like that
they slightly updated everyone's
costumes for toy appeal because they
look good enough the first time please
stop fiddling with the designs it was
already good god why do her gloves look
like that why does he have to have these
stripes please stop doing this movies
spider-man 2099 jumps into action to
throw hands with miles because he had
the black and red costume before it was
cool but a magic spell called poor
inking and coloring made the entire
world forget
it's a superhero staple you gotta have a
misunderstanding where they fight for a
little bit before teaming up against the
common foe uh except miguel says that's
stupid and doesn't do that in the comics
but whatever no one actually read that
run they only remember this guy from
shattered dimensions where he sounded
like bumblebee and was more obviously
blue but of course the first
spider-verse movie is amazing so
hopefully this is even better even
though it'll have a lot to live up to my
biggest concern is adding too many
alternate universe spider people that
don't really add anything to the story
and just make it too hard to focus on
who the main character is you know like
the spider-verse comic keep it focused
on miles he's our boy everyone else is
secondary yes even you spider-ham in
other news mortal kombat 2 has been
announced and i'm eager to watch it
because i actually like the first one
yeah i'm dumb and yes the movie is dumb
mindless silly violent schlock but
that's what i look for in mortal kombat
all i want is for them to have more
interesting main characters and he's
back on the scorpion dick writing
like yes we get it he's everyone's
favorite character he's my favorite
character but he went from being just
one of the many fighters on the roster
to
he's so cool and important that all
characters with powers are direct
descendants of him and explicitly have
powers because they're related to such a
cool and important guy who is cool and
important i hope johnny cage is in this
one to be the comic relief since kano
died
i'd also like to see smoke and the rest
of the lin quay gang become robots
because that's my favorite side story in
the mk universe
there's logos cosplay i did i really
like talking about mortal kombat but no
one [ __ ] watches it when i do so
speaking of hollywood using the same 20
actors and everything ever just about
the same time as that announcement the
rock announced that he's going to be in
another major video game movie
adaptation soon and it's one that he
plays quite often
maybe he'll be shao khan or something if
his ego would allow him to actually play
a villain again for the first time since
doom
or maybe they'll make a fortnight movie
or whatever i don't know
mortal kombat and sonic are the only
ones i like
i think they should never adapt resident
evil again i'm glad everyone instantly
forgot that terrible attempt last year
and it made no money
and making a tv show out of the last of
us is redundant because the game is
already such a cinematic experience
hey kids you want to see the exact same
thing you saw already but with one layer
of what made it interesting and
impressive totally stripped away
now you don't get to experience these
events yourself in an immersive
environment you can just put your hands
in your pockets while a bunch of actors
do that work for you hollywood sure is
weird
see this beautifully crafted
hand-painted detailed rendering and
animation well cartoons and 3d rendered
vid games aren't real storytelling so
let's recreate that by just pointing a
camera at an actor on a green screen
while the entire rest of the frame is a
3d rendered cartoon it's more valid as
an art style because 15 of the frame has
live action footage composited in and
looks like [ __ ] if i'm rambling more
this time it's because these are hard to
write when they haven't announced a lot
of new stuff and it's a dry season this
time of year marvel's avengers is adding
the black and red suit from spider-man
far from home for like 14
you can get that for free in the
insomniac game
or spend like the same amount for it in
fortnight but the mask is removable and
he gets a backpack and a baseball bat
and is in diet of pine four in an
emotional tick tock story that'll surely
have an
a 45 year old unsatisfied named rob or
something john romita jr is back drawing
the amazing spider-man after like 15
years he's the best artist that nobody
respects bunch of damn gaba ghouls think
the only valid art style is photo
realism
let the man do some stylization the
poses are dynamic he's got great layouts
playstation exclusive games are getting
pc ports so people can mod kratos to
have a giant head and probably put up
trace in a stormtrooper outfit or some
other ridiculous things i personally
hope someone mods it so kratos model is
replaced with nemesis from resident evil
so we can see if the emotions hit his
heart if he looks like a third degree
burn victim with a xenomorph mouth and
like a
sideways nose
if those spider-man games get ported to
i know everyone's gonna swap his face
model with the old one so that'll be
funny i mean i don't care that much
about that [ __ ] anymore but but yeah
everyone
everyone's still really mad about that
new star wars video games coming down
the pipe including a sequel to fallen
order an untitled first person shooter
and a strategy game this is in addition
to the star wars game at quantic dream
which is uh
certainly a bold choice given
recent news i'll just stick to lego star
wars
geez
all right
what else what else what else what else
uh winnie the pooh is public domain so
here's a brief cartoon of him robbing a
bank
i'll let jacob and ben figure out what
that looks like
what happened to the rest of the guys
madame web movie starring dakota johnson
is in early development which is strange
because madame webb is an elderly french
woman no one remembers she's french who
can't leave the chair she sits on all
day without dying so she'll probably be
the other madame webb and the original
is yet to be cast big ups to julia
carpenter for being one of the only
marvel superheroes from colorado
[Music]
and also for being a good sport because
spider-man stole her costume ideas
because he's a punk
there i talked about moon knight you
can't say i didn't talk about moon
knight there you go no i won't do a
video on no way home i have nothing to
say about it it's a good movie though
you should come back next time we'll see
you 90s electric guitars we all know the
real gutter space is where i'd be living
if not for sponsors like squarespace
squarespace gives you a user-friendly
and beautiful platform to maintain and
run your very own website you can
connect with your site's users through
gated members only content as well as
sending email notifications leverage
audience insights all on one easy to use
platform you can create your own
community with comments sections with
threaded comments and likes these handy
blogging tools built in can help you
easily categorize and share posts on the
site you can get even more from
squarespace with third-party extensions
to manage inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping or whatever else
your site needs to run like a well-oiled
machine and you can even display posts
from your social media on your site to
make sure your followers are connected
and can share them too go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash this
special code to save ten percent off
your first purchase for a website or
domain
[Music]
you